Hey, it's Keri with Buzz60.
A new app that originated in China is now trending on iTunes...
...and it's called MyIdol.
It is quickly taking over social media.
It takes a selfie and then it turns it into this amazing cartoon, like this.
You take a picture and then upload it to the app...
...and you have all kinds of choices of hair and clothes.
Then you get to choose the activity and soundtrack.
Definitely avoid "Let It Go."
Most people are choosing pole dancing.
Then you get a picture like this, which you share with your friends.
You can move on in creating MyIdol images with famous pictures too.
Of course, the 1D fandom is loving this app...
...that lets them be the puppet masters of their favorite boy band.
Louis is dancing like a female pop star from the 90s...
...and Niall is taking his turn on the pole or Vladimir Putin on a pole.
Or Nick Jonas just hanging out.